cheese
Christmas
[Music]
you know
foreign
[Music]
laughs
knock knock
thank you
I am currently in Alabama Hills which if
you would ever tell me that I'd be in
Alabama Hills in August I'd think you
were
out of your mind
I assumed it would be ungodly hot down
here but it's actually amazing
there's a breeze and there's um cloud
cover I think the storm is potentially
moving in there's hardly anyone here
that's the best part there is actually a
road closed coming out here and you had
to take a fairly long detour to get out
to this camping area so it's mostly
deserted and I'm loving it in the last
video I told you guys I'd give you a
little tour of Brett's fan and it's been
so interesting living in his van
um so different than mine and some
things are I'm getting really spoiled
like not having to make my bed every
morning having this elevator bed is
so luxury I also have an oven and I just
um have so much space to like walk
around and the van is a very open air
minimalist design and it's really
beautiful like Brett always does an
incredible job he just has such talent
for building so
it's been it's been a really cool
experience yesterday was especially
interesting
um I kind of got myself into a situation
I was looking for a new campsite and
I wandered off down this road in Mammoth
Lakes and um the road kind of curved
around this tree and the one rule that I
always know that I broke
is when you can't see where the road is
going get out and take a look before you
drive down it and I did not do that and
it was a really big mistake the road was
like for ATVs dirt bikes dune buggies it
was not meant for vehicles as especially
a tall van like this if it was Steep and
descending and swirling and terrifying
basically slid like like a bobsled down
the spiral
um and I just thought oh my gosh when I
get to the bottom hopefully the sand
will be like it'll be hard packed and I
can turn around and try to gun it back
up that hill it was just a sand pit like
I immediately sunk into the sand I got
out and started digging uh with my hands
finally after some you know maneuvering
of the sand I got like a little inch and
then I got another inch another inch and
I I did like a 14 point turn out of
there and then I had to try to go up
that freaking Hill again I just ended up
putting the pedal to the metal doing my
best to not fly off the side of of the
Steep Hill as I was going up because I
couldn't really gain that much momentum
because I had to also steer as I was
going up and when I got to the top of
that Hill I was just like
screaming I was so thankful so freaking
thankful and so impressed by this band
so I've been living in this fan for
about a week for three weeks Brett and I
were in Mammoth Lakes and he was doing
the build I was helping here and there
but I also had a lot of work projects so
it was kind of like helping with that
and you know balancing the two and then
we had to switch up locations and so he
took my van down to his Workshop in
Southern California and I had to stay
back in Mammoth Lakes to do some
shooting and finish up some work
projects so I thought I would just give
you guys a really quick tour of this van
um show you a couple of the cool
features things that I'm loving
hopefully we'll get some pink skies and
Stormy Weather maybe and I can show you
guys the views out here here we have the
kitchen and we have this overhead cabin
storage up here latches in really solid
so that when you're driving it doesn't
budge
we also have a stove top and an oven can
you believe this an oven here is the
fridge
the sink
[Music]
foreign
I have all my camera gear in here and
then my clothes and these here smart
Cabinetry storage
here we have the remote for the max air
fan and the control for the diesel
heater check this out Brett keeps a
record player in the van
this here is extra storage but it's also
an ottoman that you can kind of move
around so that you have a foot rest here
we have more controller storage I put
camera gear in there right now
over here we have the electrical
compartment
under this other seat is a 20 gallon
water tank this sliding door window is
actually one of my favorite features it
actually has a built-in screen door
which I would love love love to have in
my van it's so nice for airflow that
there is my toilet that I put in this
van because I can't live without it here
is my favorite feature
[Music]
this elevator bed seriously getting so
spoiled by this
it's so so nice not having to make my
bed from an office into bed every single
night and morning it's also really nice
to have the option of an oven and to
have 20 gallons of water so I don't have
to refill quite as often I love love the
open minimalistic design everything is
so well done and it's really pretty and
of course my favorite feature is that
it's 4x4 that's huge like I would love
to have 4x4 on my van cons for me with
this van the number one reason is just
that I'm Too Tall
um I hit my head on this I have to duck
down a little bit when I walk underneath
so that's something to keep in mind if
you are on the taller side I'm five nine
and the second thing is just that I have
too much stuff like there's not enough
storage in this van I mean there is I
should probably just get rid of a lot of
my stuff but as it stands with all my
camera gear and backpacking gear and
paddle board and bike and crap there's
just no way it would fit in here so you
know if you're more minimalistic than me
and
um you like this Vibe which I assure you
it is very sweet Zen Vibe this band is
actually for sale so you can hit a Brett
if you want to check it out I'm gonna go
catch Sunset and take you guys with me
foreign
[Music]
how it felt like home
all these times
[Music]
please
foreign
[Applause]